can we talk about what the [ __ ] going
on in san francisco
what
always i just want you to explain the
bipping culture to everyone because i i
uh i feel like it's been getting more
national because it's always been a
thing in the bay
i feel like more recently everyone
started to find out about like
bipping in general like if you go to san
francisco really specifically the city
right
like if you have oakland too if you have
a rental car yeah
like your car is going to get broken
into like
perspective it's almost guaranteed i can
guarantee you even i can't avoid it
so i know some people will go to the bay
like when we when i'm moving around i
just take everything with me out of the
car
but i mean some people will just keep
all their windows down that's how we do
look i'll tell you i
i'll read you the text messages i just
sent to earth game they just played
uh i think the new parish
a couple days ago like two days ago
and
i told this dude hey bro
don't keep nothing in the car i don't
know i said also it is imperative that
you do not leave anything in the car
anywhere in the bay especially in
oakland or san francisco downtown watch
the vehicles at all times and if you get
out the car keep all the windows rolled
down just a little so you can peek onto
the seats don't leave anything inside
that [ __ ] even if you're just getting
out to pump gas get some gum sparkle
lighter or go in the store
have you been bipped uh-huh how many
times just once and my bip experience
was traumatic we took the [ __ ] on the
high speed chase i was
what happened man i just was doing too
much chasing these [ __ ] on the freeway
with my little brother so they hit your
car
and you gotta i get out the car they hit
the other window as soon as we get out
we don't even hear you know the bipper
silence
glad i think chance heard it a little
bit he i turned turn around he running
so i run out of the store that we just
walked in this is all in
50 seconds at most
literally you get out of the car yeah
they're on they pull up on the other
side
um
so we chased him followed him down catch
him on the freeway
and
it was the it was one of the coldest
moments me and my little brother was
just talking about this too because
this is my first time really coming into
my like oakland celebrity like that like
i'm getting bigger back home right
i was at the oakland airport never
rented a car before but i finally got my
driver's license i'm ready to rent a car
i'm like i'm old enough this is my first
rental whatever can't get one from
nobody till we see a lady at the end and
she like
what you go up there at 4 000. man you
sheila's son we so proud of you what
kind of what you need yeah yeah so i'm
like okay let me get this i get to
sleeve it's good
we in the suburban i'm i just think
about that lady as we are now a couple
hours later on the high speed chase
trying to follow this [ __ ]
blue infinity down 580 80 to catch him
and literally my brother driving and i
looked in his eyes and i could see he
thinking about that [ __ ] too like [ __ ]
we do i do not want to embarrass my mama
and crash this rental and then ruin all
this [ __ ] for all this good talk that
this lady right just almost had tears in
her eyes she was so proud of me
i was so [ __ ] hot bro
then we cut the car off
and i'm finna bounce out but i don't
have nothing and i'm irritated because
we don't know if they got guns or not
but people usually don't bit with guns
for the most part right cause if they
get caught it's over but if they don't
get caught they not even going to jail
even if they do if there's no firearm in
here
but
they squeeze through us on the divider
because we try to cut them off i'm going
to land there on the last line they
squeeze through us sandwich they carve
get up out of there
they get off the freeway ramp on 35th by
this high school skyline that's how i
know the exit oakland [ __ ]
and i get out the car i fall out the
[ __ ] car running up to him i'm
trying to pick some up to throw through
the back of the window they trapped and
some cars seen us running after them and
tried to cone them in and then they
pushed through they [ __ ] broke they
whole [ __ ] off the whole front of the
[ __ ] was broken and got on the
freeway on the other side and got away
oh i was so hot cause literally i was
leaving coming from the airport
i was at the store because we finished
shoot some [ __ ] a music video at this
store so i went over there to scout the
location and it's early i didn't even
checked into my room yet i was out the
car for 60 seconds it happened to me
like that i'm in oakland for less than
an hour already chasing [ __ ] on the
freeway would they take they took a uh
my gucci bag with the ipad and my
headphones
i would've just let them have that
i was hot i was seeing red